so
let us honor our heroes by doing that
let us
open our schools and open our economy by
testing testing testing
testing
tracing treating isolation
these schools are saying they should be
six feet apart that's for sure
you're going to need fewer people in the
classroom so you need more space
therefore you need more teachers and the
president is saying if you don't open up
we're going to deprive you of the
8 point something percent that the
federal government provides
to state to to schools in our country
state and local do over 90 percent of it
and we and they have again
serious budget deficits because of the
coronavirus
so um again we need
we need um we need the dpa
to open up schools to open up the
economy
to open up the economy and we need to
help america's families
actually if you put it all together in
our two packages
we have two 230 billion dollars
specifically for the schools
and then we have nearly a trillion
dollars for state and local government
which i remind you
is one half of what they gave away in
their tax break 83
of the benefits going to the top one
percent
so in any case um
mr president admit it you've gone down
the wrong path
ask for direction ask for direction from
our scientists
who know better they knew better
as we urge the president and the gop
senate to get on it
and help the american people help our
state and local governments by honoring
our heroes
open up our economy and our schools by
having the equipment needed to do it and
the funds
to facilitate that put money in the
pockets of the american people the time
is running
out on that this is drastic i know
we keep saying this over and over but it
still persists
and the clock is running out on it but
as we urge them to do that
uh house democrats are still working
very hard for the people
this week the appropriations committee
has been marking up
the fiscal year 2021 legislation put us
on track to have passed legislation
uh to fund 96 of the government
in july for the second time in two years
we have been
on schedule uh we will pass those bills
next week they're being marked up this
week and last week
we're holding nearly 30 hearings and
markups
as we are here now across committees
including energy and commerce markup
yesterday uh at this time some of it
yesterday
30 health related bills and hearings on
covet relief and vaccine pandemic
preparedness
environmental justice in the era of
covet and much more
so we have a lot going on we will be
taking these votes to the floor
next week to be
on schedule to meet the needs
of the american people and again
the clock is ticking the unemployment
insurance will run out by the end of the
month
even before the end of the month uh we
need to have the direct payments to
people
but on the subject of the kids you know
i'm a grandmother
my mom five kids nine grandchildren all
ages
um the youngest one in public school in
san francisco
were very concerned not only for her but
for her classmates they don't
all have all of the technology
that would be needed for distance
learning all of that many of them
go to school for meals now they go to
school to learn
but they get their food there and so
with all the
uh concern that we have for all children
we have to make sure all of that
uh is in place but that's a a situation
that's replicated across the country
and so instead of threatening schools
instead of the secretary of education
saying
children should take risks astronauts
take risks oh really
oh really so in any event
um this is personal
it's about our children
and at the very least the president
could say we have we're going to have
the equipment necessary
any questions yes ma'am speaker
you're talking about spending billions
upon trillions more
yes money on this bill and you and mitch
mcconnell still not agreed
different suggestions about it and we
came to a conclusion about
an excellent person
and he agreed but there's some process
in the senate which i was not aware of
that takes a lot of time and that was
a deterrent for the person staying on
board that moment
yes yes
well i've proposed someone to the the
leader
and we'll see if he accepts but i won't
be
announcing it right here but this is you
know
it's a funny thing you would think it
should be the easiest thing in the world
to come to such a conclusion and
i was particularly proud that
general dunford was interested in
considering this because i do think
that a person of his stature and in the
military
person who knows how to manage things a
leader
completely apolitical would have been
the perfect person
i just don't know a how the word got out
about him before
there was an announcement which uh then
made well what are we waiting for part
of the issue so
i would i would hope that we would have
somebody uh
there are plenty of people in the
military who
would i think be willing to exercise
their patriotic duty in an
apolitical way with their management
skills and the rest and that's what i'm
hoping will happen
yes sir do you have any contact with
anyone in the administration
over this next package package
the um everything in this package
except for like say 95 of what is in
this package
is what we have had in previous bills
so nobody is being asked to vote for
something they haven't voted for before
the one thing that is different is they
have resisted
in the past any strong osha standard
and that is absolutely essential for us
to have to protect our workers
at all times but an intense a
a strong even stronger one at the time
of coronavirus
so they know what they have to do
there is another piece that they have
resisted
that is very urgent now
they resisted in the cares and it's very
urgent now
and that is the assistance for renters
the moratorium the moratorium is going
to end
and or has ended in some places
and we really need to get that
assistance and that
not only do we have it in the heroes act
but a couple of weeks ago
we passed it on the floor of the house
as a separate bill
200 billion dollars 100 billion uh to
help with renters
75 billion in addressing the
mortgage forbearance uh
foreclosure forbearance issue and then
the rest of it for homeless
homelessness and special rural health
housing programs and the rest
they really have to do this this is very
very urgent
now that would be something they haven't
voted for bef
haven't supported before as well
as they haven't supported a strong
worker protection
osha standard but other than that
they've
supported state and local government
they've supported
testing they've supported
direct payments they've supported
unemployment benefits one time they
supported
they even supported food stamps they've
resisted since then
even though people who've never been to
a food line before
a food bank before are in long lines
to get in you would think they'd have
some sensitivity on emergency food
initiatives including uh snap
on the food bank so that would be one
where they have resisted
but they have voted for before anybody
in the administration about what
their feeling is well we have we have
conversations on individual things
and members republican senators have
approached me about individuals
they know there's going to be a bill and
we uh
first it was going to be no bill and
then it was going to be
some little bill now it's 1.3
it's not enough it's not enough and when
they say it's too expensive
how can they say such a thing when right
now the fed is
just propping up the stock market
stock market looks good huh well federal
dollars are helping to make
that happen and that's okay and that's a
good thing for the economy
but we should have trillions of dollars
to prop up
workers we've never seen anything like
this
so on one subject or another but it also
just gets me that they say oh it's too
expensive
two trillion dollars that's what they
added to the deficit to pass their tax
scam a couple years ago
which gave 83 of the benefits
to the top one percent
i mean like in the cast system mode
whatever we can do at the top
that's what we really like to do perhaps
it will trickle down
if it does that would be good if it
doesn't as they have said
so be it but we have to make
make the fight and we know that it will
happen they have to do unemployment
insurance
democrats and republicans across the
country are
calling out for them to do the state and
local
republican mayors and county executives
governors
they need that money they have outlays
for coronavirus and they have revenue
loss because of chronobytes
so they'll be there yes
thank you madam speaker the
administration and some republicans are
proposing the idea of
back to work return to work bonuses for
employees
what's your thought on that and would
you consider including that in the next
video
i don't know if they know what they're
talking about so i can't really
thoughtfully address what you just asked
but i will say this
uh testing testing testing
people do not want to risk their lives
and that of their families by going to
work that isn't
safe we can open the economy
if we make it safe for people to go back
to work
are they going to pay people to risk
their lives without any osha standard
and the rest people are not
staying home they want to work
they want to go to work in a safe place
so the direction that the president
should be asking for is how do we open
our economy to make it safe
for people to go to work
and it is so self-evident
yes sir uh madam speaker i have a
question and i have a colleague who has
a second question if you'll allow
for them is that person here no
they're not able to be here one per
outlet well that's up to the rest of you
do you want somebody who is in here to
have a question before you do
my question is um just that you know a
few months ago
um it was hard to predict that we would
have such severe spikes i guess now
in july other countries clearly have
handled this in a way that we have not
moving forward if in the next couple of
months we still don't have a full grasp
on it is there a point where
trillions more in stimulus just becomes
unsustainable
no i mean the point is if we don't
invest the money
now it'll be much worse if we don't
invest in further
testing and getting the equipment to do
it it will be worse
if we don't put money in the pockets of
the american people
with our on direct payments and
unemployment
insurance it will be much worse if
people are being fired at the state and
local level
being health care workers transit
workers teachers
sanitation workers and the rest it will
be much
worse so this is what is about survival
of our economy and it is about spending
the money
in a way in a way that brings us back
and
don't take it from me the chairman of
the fed he even recommended state and
local he said
i right i called to congress's attention
state and local government
really we already have it in the heroes
act uh the
uh secretary of of the treasury knows
uh that we have to do more to uh
uh prop up our economy or else it will
be worse
it will be worse your next question is
the president today is going to be
talking about uh how his administration
has been rolling back regulation
um over the past four years and helping
americans rise out of poverty
he's doing that from the white house
today it doesn't i don't know i'm sorry
i don't know what he's doing today what
are you doing today
today the president is supposed to be
talking about um his administration
rolling back regulation and
helping americans rise out of poverty i
don't know what he's doing
but i want to tell you something what he
did this week in terms of nepa and what
richard nixon richard nixon put in place
uh for to protect our environment and
therefore the good health of the
american people
oh some of the um shall we say polluters
were saluting it
but it was a wrong thing to do so i
don't know what specific
um danger to the environment or the
health and well-being of america's
families and workers he's considering
today
but if it's anything like what he has
been doing uh
that's most unfortunate but i'll tell
you this
he's done a lot of bad things but nobody
you can't tell
whether it's methane or mercury or uh
what he's doing to the environment
once or twice a week terrible things
that have an impact on the health and
well-being of the american people
the air our children breathe the water
they drink
but what does he do but say i'm i've got
beans on my desk and that's what people
cover
instead of the danger that he is
proposing
to our country and his administration
he has the henchmen
of the polluters in his cabinet always
has
and and he's implementing an agenda
that's he's going to rise up people from
poverty by making him
breathe foul air i don't get it yes
anyone else yes sir on unemployment you
mentioned that the benefit is going to
uh
to end even before the first of august
the way that the system is structured
um and yesterday you seemed to indicate
some flexibility on the 600
figure that had been in demand of the
democrats what would be an appropriate
replacement for that 600
figure if you were to reduce that a
little bit no i'm all for the 600
uh but again if they what i said was the
whole package
will depend on the uh
what we do also for direct payments
which are so
essential it may be hard for them to
understand why they're so
busy giving 83 percent of the benefits
to the top one percent in our country
that people really do need this money
baby needs a pair of shoes this is
urgent
they need to buy food they this is these
are necessities
and when people use that money
for necessities they inject demand into
the economy and create jobs
and create jobs so it is a stimulus but
it's more than a stimulus it is a
necessity
right now so
so when they're giving away all this big
money
and they worry about 600 for families
who need it so desperately
it just it just makes you wonder who are
they here for
i always say um i haven't quoted him
lately
maybe i have saint augustine
1700 years ago
17 centuries ago saint augustine
said any government that is not
formed to promote justice is just
a bunch of thieves this is about justice
it's so hard for people i have so many
challenges
fear of catching a virus that could be
deadly but nonetheless debilitating
and have pre-conditioned pre-existing
condition
challenges for them as they go forward
economic insecurity that they have
uncertainty about their children going
to school
and is that safe while the president is
threatening
to take away money from the poorest kids
by the way in many cases
title one funding for children in
economically disadvantaged areas
separate from that but including some of
that
children with disabilities homeless
children
that's a chunk of what the federal
government puts
into into it so we're in a moment of
making a judgment where is justice
where's justice in the environment as
they roll back
environmental standards of clean air
clean water which affect
communities of color in a
disproportionate way where's the justice
of taking away
funding from the from many of the
poorest kids or children with
disabilities
to act like a big guy where's the
justice
in uh and not having the testing of the
coronavirus
so that we can see and and the
statistics and data
so that we can see that the
disproportionate impact that it has on
people of color and it does
what is the justice of them taking down
the website practically i understand of
cdc so that we can see uh what the
challenges are to hospitals and the rest
and then saying we're not going to have
people report
to the cdc a scientific organization
we're going to have them support reports
of the administration
and where is the transparency we're
going to tell us about that and one of
the bills
the second ppp bill when we put more
testing in there
we required that they would have
collect the data and report the data
as to how especially communities of
color were affected because we
didn't have much of that and because
that's a place where there
hasn't been a commensurate amount of
testing
the hispanic community and the
african-american community we're all
americans
we're all americans and everybody and
all of our children
are important to us all of our people
are and because we are americans we're
going to beat this
but we have to beat it scientifically
and in order to to do that you have to
believe in
science and you have to believe in
governance
now a friend who asked the question
about how they're going to lift up
everybody out of poverty by taking away
regulations uh probably would not like
me to hear me say
that they don't believe in governance
if you don't believe in governance and
you don't believe in science
you don't want to do anything and you
don't have to because you don't have the
data
that you accept so we're in a very
critical place i yearn for other
republican presidents
while we may have disagreed on many
points at least we had a shared
commitment to the governance of our
country
richard nixon signed the nepa
legislation
so in any case that's it's it's a
i said yesterday we're at another
critical point
but this is getting to be uh
as i said to you look at all the number
of people 50 million
more people have died since they haven't
taken up the bill
and a large number more have um
a large number more have become uh
infected
next week though we're going to have
some 137 000
since we passed the bill under 37 000
um are dead now but 50 000
added to that and then 2 million more
people infected adding to 3.4
but let me just tell you next week what
you're going to see we're going to have
child care bills on the floor
to ensure that parents can go back to
work and child care workers
can keep their jobs this is very
very important and a very high priority
for us
and then we're going to have the great
outdoors act a bipartisan bill
that passed the senate and and
we will be protecting our national hair
our natural heritage with that and then
honoring our values with the no ban
act we'll be passing the no ban act and
access to council so we have a number of
things
including we're going to be passing
bills next week or the
this next week or the next about
removing statues from the capital
of people who have committed treason
against the united states of america
so we have a we're busy we're full but
nothing more important than the lives
of our children our children our
children
and their ability to go back to school
which we all want them to do and they
want to do and teachers want to do and
parents want them to do
but they can't do it if it isn't safe
it can be safe if the president executes
the defense production act to make sure
it does
thank you all very much